en fait c'est comme ça que des cadres au
toit ce que je peux je serais mort cat's
paw s'en fout vous me deviné c'est comme
ça ouais comme ça tu es carré alors fava
temps avoir déjà si on est en ligne si
ça marche c'est des gens oui sur twitter
a toujours tendance à mon pire sera en
replay sur youtube du coup il y aura des
gens alors sa compagne qui décrivent
dans le chat pour vérifier qu'ils soient
bien en ligne ça m'évite d'ouvrir 40
fenêtres et après on va peut-être
commencer par regarder un petit peu
cette finale fab se joue c'est fini
c'est la seule partie qui joue ok donc
plus que donc pour chronique je pense
qu'on peut mettre ça en fil rouge et
faire un peu discuté ce que web en ce
moment on va se tourner en achetant un
peu parce qu'à une plus intéressant que
des beats en ligne quand même pas de
profiter des tournois renouvellement le
temps de de blitz et de faire les
guignols a pour une fois pas quelque
chose d'intéressant pendant le stream du
jeudi d'actualité sous que c'est une
finale intéressante champions plus pour
cramique des choses les derniers coups
oui lorsqu'on arrive janvier quelques
cousins donc au piège pour cette bref un
rejet si pdci
je pense pas mais je pensais être juste
en bessin que c'est quoi son nez devient
peut-être à lyon j'en ressens kf4 et oui
beaucoup d'activités pour les normes et
que en plus de 1000 kg 5 pouvoir
peut-être récupérer un pion plus tard
aux quêteurs b5 jouer après je suis
quasiment sûr que ces quatre jeux au
pied de dix mois d'août et du couvent
oui aussi tu as fait l'écho c'est un
lien juste savoir ce que c'est sur le
strip ce petit truc ici rouge petit truc
rouge
non mais attends c'est juste que ça oui
ok j'ai compris ces gens qui se
connectent du coup un viennent un peu
sur la fenêtre
oria marion et consorts tout le monde
youkai ces quatre d'accord ces cinq pays
restait michaels stores beckham ont fait
tour s'est vite force à tour ses 5 qui
fait ressortir le 3g maginifique aller à
3 mais peut-être qu'il est sain non mais
n'importe quoi pendant enfin peut-être
se passer des villes venant j'ai pas
jusqu'où je suis plutôt envie de faire
car avec quatre vestes kfk 3 et 5 passes
en carrière
bon et puis ton teint peu nombreux fait
qu'elle était quatre pour f2
peu après au pire ok là on fait un truc
avec g5 ya des f4 et ça va mais je pense
qu'ils sont en train de répéter invoqué
chronique peut tenter de l'embêter un
peu donc on a que marion dans le chat
pour l'instant après voilà c'est des
trucs à nous demander on discute un peu
après on verra ce qu'on fait on suit la
partie en direct de crem nique et
reliance et un gameplay syfy qui a eu 3
c'est fini
sauf votre enfant mon nom mais c'est à
dire que le hasard va tomber 5 à mon
avis ne va pas il va changer après deux
cas ici quatre taxes va ce truc russe
voiture avec deux fois et usant te dit
non vous pour le gain est donc sinon
dans votre chasse que des nuls
aujourd'hui et pas de parti vraiment
emballante
bah non c'est un peu le problème de
tournon actuelle un peu de parties
emballante
enfin là ils sont quand même en train de
battre tous les records qui est le grand
prix de chargeur est assez costaud ce
point de vue là non non non mais là
c'est encore pire à temps les gens les
gens attendent jugement vérifier ce que
personne ne me confirme que ça marche
vraiment du coup je suis pas sûr que ça
marche juste vérifier hockey dans la
philosophie
non mais la rebelle bosco dit oh you
boys nom du tournoi et on a pas très
emballant fab et bâle a en fait cette
partie qu'elle part elle illustre bien
le tournoi en fait non mais quelques pas
ouais mais bon en même temps ils ont
quatre jeux 50 cougot - ou winger la
position finale - c'est un registre un
peu les parties qu'on a un peu
rapidement karlsson a que moi peut-être
s'est passé comment c'était dernièrement
alors carlos n1 camurat tué au moins un
petit perpète donc d'un âge d'or
h3 j'avais bu gsi g3 donc transposé un
dragon vendangé trois qui paient le plus
offensif mais au moins provoc à 6 chez
les noirs qui pas forcément tout envie
de jouer et ils on va dire justement
prévoit qu'elle est sa guise et 4 voilà
oui peut-être faire qui est des cinq
essais qu'atlus lui même pour faire une
sorte de marie-odile je sais pas voilà
un petit quelque chose quand même ici
magnusson bien ce genre de chose près on
m'a sûrement nakamura joue pas mal
puisqu'il a bien tenu le 5 responsable
mais le truc c'est qu'il veut
éventuellement je pense qui est
peut-être cette case plus tard avec
l'amp ce cavalier qui va bondir leila
donc les blancs n'ont plus de cavaliers
sur ces trois cases ou de shoot cases
noires pour profiter ça très bien au
quesnoy en amener un cahier sur des cas
là il jouait de manière très responsable
et très dynamique est moins méfiants et
réussir en changeant des simples qui
rechange une structure de pian web est
le truc c'est qu'à long terme c'est bien
pour le nord puisque on aura le cavalier
contre le mauvais fou
frère qui est le seul truc c'est que
pendant ce temps carlson contrôle bien
la seule colonne ouverte
oui puis peut avoir aussi des idées à
certains grâce à cette colonne dans ces
quatre d'avoir aussi des menaces émanant
les événements en fait inquiétant c'est
un qui est bloc à 3 on va lui passer son
pion 40h dynamique pour pour les blancs
mais on n'a qu'à me rase pas mal
débrouillé dans tout semble jouer en
hiver et au cap où le roi blanc
du coup parti ultra pect nos stats à 100
duco maka qui amène tous ces pièces d'or
le roi option de plus pour ma muse
analyser ça avec un ordinateur chapeau
one on me l'a juste pour qu'on regarde
ensemble qu'on nous annule en fait voilà
ce qu'est preuve de oui pardon je dois
faire un registre bien tranquille dans
aux prises échec et chacun parle bien de
quoi les échecs et c'est nul donc que
c'était maintenant partie gtt feu on
sera regardé la vidéo sur castrophe
d'aujourd'hui et bim vous serez pour
empêcher de regarder la vidéo jusqu'à la
fin où partent à l'aise jusqu'à la fin
possible
du coup on regarde peut-être un peu
maxim roy contre roy je ne peux pas
continuer
il faut rappeler qu on n'a pas le droit
de proposer les nuls donc une petite
petrov s'est interdit totalement où il
ya j'en retire avec l annonce à atari
totalement arbitres qui vient te dire
que tu peux faire mieux pour ça que
aronian il est parti hier david lui a
dit tu n'as pas le faire est une
solution complètement nu il a dit tu ne
respectes pas d'une joue plus je pars je
parte ses comptes qu'il y a
je sais plus
cette pas contre car ya kim ce qu'il a
parlé car yakine en partant il inquiété
et curé mais je suis plus content qu'il
s'était du coup la position était
vraiment nul
ok donc que du coup petrov et 3 t à
choquer c'est très jouable tourner sur
mon genre ont dû lui aussi quasi égal ou
peut-être les pions des cinq un petit
peu faible cote de mme b je pense à des
drapeaux à trois mais je passe toutes
deux tout nul na li d'échangés de fouet
par la case de 5 que tu me diras tu
avais un kényan s'est si souvent 17 et
puis voilà un briquet il a obtenu un
tout petit quelque chose après dans la
partie comme on l'a vu il va réussir un
tout petit peu attaqué le pionner 5 mais
en fait ça défend bien pour les noirs
cet échange sur des saints qui aura
l'autre qui donnait en 18 à 20 heures
stade au parti non mais très solide dans
le pétrole s'est cassé les dents dessus
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais trop compris
pourquoi cela disparu au niveau c'était
hyper là où dans les années 2000 ramires
à guelph en même temps pas là fait un
peu et c'est bon c'était fini mais on ne
l'a plus
et là il ya les chinois qui sont n'y a
pas la jouer et
puis caruana loi et puis en fait les
personnes trouvent trop grand chose quoi
donc
non en fait le truc c'est que c'est un
petit peu partout complètement égal
oui je vais à mon rythme en garde la
paix trace est complètement égal dans la
carro cana si c'est elle la française
ok mais je sais pas je ne peux plus la
berlinois alors à carreaux cannes
finances d'avancé sur des pièces non je
n'ai pas tapé trop loin que la structure
symétrique
mais j ça en rigolant non mais jugé hier
que tu rigoles même par ailleurs vice
tellement égale partout qui peuvent être
des modes
est ce que je veux dire c'est un truc et
des trucs plus simple virtual non
c'était vraiment le genre la partie du
jour de carrier keane
on va vous la montrer la compet pour
répondre à pina deuce c'est
c'est de norwich est ce donc natoora
fermé en norvège avec les dix meilleures
jambes en deux points ex divergent en
banlieue on va dire et
donc à magnus qui joue ya caruana il ya
maxime wesley so il ya cram nika
nakamura
il ya un an 10 à rognan et à kariat qui
n'y élit et puis voilà mais déjà ouais
donc beau tournoi simplement il fait des
beaux noms mais en fait on ne l'a pas
sadique c'est un autre match de foot
genre tu vois les choses un peu real
barça mais mais les mecs qui font que la
passe qui se font des passes à dix ça
fallait très très bons joueurs ne
perdent jamais le ballon comme 06400 et
au kansas et la fameuse partie en fait
je pense juste à nantes joue un peu sa
prépa l'orchestré de quel dessein que
j'avais vu une partie en top 12 entre
piorun je crois avec les blancs contre
criera au secours est arrivé à gagner
je crois qu'avec les noirs qui ont
choisi le cap des 6
en fait tu les prix pions prend juste
une structure horrible on tourne plus à
perdre tout simplement ça sort pas ouais
et c'était très difficile en pratique au
moins peut-être lors du donne également
sa rien comme d'hab mais ok chiant à
jouer et il a gagné avec les blancs
après une longue partie et donc à nantes
joue différemment simplement la fusée 5
au guide en l'air ne peut pas prendre ce
qu'il a lu la aux maths du couloir f6 il
s'en va fou prend b2 mon seul problème
sur vous est peut-être ce fou à être
enfermés mais ok juste un nom à tout
analyser et s'en fiche mais il fait ses
6 contres attaques lecavalier qui défend
ce pion donc là ça peut faire peur à
bercy on n'a jamais eu la position va
pas rentrer là dedans comme ça que les
noirs gérard hyper par écrit noir les
sites analysés en fait tu sais être lors
des votes 2 0 et puis et puis voilà un
petit échange tout et puis voilà fin de
partie les filles très vite je pense en
moins d'une heure je sais tu es ste anne
marie enfin là l'après dit jeudi prêt à
utiliser chaque classiques seront finis
dans moins de cinq ans que ça n'existera
juste plus fort là va très loin mais en
fait il sait absolument inintéressant ça
aucun intérêt passe égale partout et
unique tout le monde en a marre en fait
les joueurs les spectateurs les
préparateurs
plus personne ne veut voir ça en fait
des vosges aux échecs 260 à 959 échec
9,5 en amenant les blattes pense
vraiment faire du cousu main les seconds
rez-de-chaussée que malgré tout ce qui
vient toujours voulu jouer aux échecs
classique parce qu'il est bien préparé
même il en a marre faf s'est jusque là
le sénégal et qu'ils apprennent tous
tous par coeur un sein du sadomasochisme
en fait ça devient complètement débile
en fait mon truc mais vu que le monde
aime l'inertie tu peux faire un truc
complètement débiles dans très longtemps
que ça dure encore 20 ans mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que c'est complètement
ridicule par un flag qui bossent tous
les jours maintenant et dit assez égale
partout dans tout le monde sait que
c'est nul tout on sait que ces câbles
mais ça continue
mais moi je sais même toi tu le sais pas
tout le sens fait du coup c'est bientôt
juste auquel moi je bosse - j'ai pas la
même préparation que quand je fais des
trucs précis ou que je sais pas jean
lous rien aux olympiades quand on
bossait avec maxime pour il avait les
blancs composite l'heure on essaie de
trouver un truc contient qu'une seule
terre j'ai passé six heures dessus pour
rien quoi parce que toute façon ni rien
quoi annuler parc juste en fait le truc
difficile
enfin le truc à faire pour eux se trouve
une idée intéressante à jouer en
pratique qui a pas été analysés si l'on
prend des trucs de gladys il quoi et
mais en fait une fois et si tu fais un
one shot en fait est ok de surprendre
l'adversaire un truc qu'il n'a pas
regardé qui plus ou moins clairement
inoffensif selon l'ordi mais quand on
pratique pas si simple votre une idée un
truc preuve c'est une fois que la jouer
toute façon c'est direct en live le
sorento monde au courant les armes et de
préparateurs semaine dessus lendemain tu
ne rejoue pas sinon c'est fermer quoi
mais du coup du truc complètement
ridicule donc en fait tu bosses des arts
pour trouver une idée une fois et quand
tu la joues fait pas de planter en plus
j'arrête choc contre maxim lapierre
finul après une agression gagnante
le goûter déconfite un deuxième prime
ces partis ne sont pas très
spectaculaires c'est que dan houser dit
à 80% des parties finisse comme ça parce
que il ya un énorme boulot d'air c'est
parti là mais ça n'a rien de bon en fait
une intéressante pas pour le commun des
mortels d'apple scientifique m mais
scientifique relou parce que fâchés pas
scientifique scientifique énergie
solaire par exemple je te dis ouais
c'est pas mal parce que je joue moins de
moins d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ça améliore la qualité de vie tout
ça donc je dis oui pourquoi pas d'autres
y voient la bbc antifi que pour bouger
trois bouts de bois sur un truc en bois
aussi je te dis un petit peu comme
einstein médicaux einstein les médias
lascars tu perds ta vie fin tu ne sers à
rien un essai ça en fait quelque part
ces façades y ait un petit peu quand
même non pas sa vie un peu too much on
met la src - spectacteurs que les partis
qu'on regarde de gary ou quoi de
l'alaska pas s'il va tenter de créer
quelque chose mais c'était beau jeu
s'est passé comme ça tu vas jouer les
simples comme une toile de peinture ok
ça
fondamentalement à rien un tableau mais
ça me donne une émotion j'ai fait
plaisir c'est beau donc là oui même si
le mec passiez pas même 200 heures pour
inventer son coup
quelque part il apporte quelque chose
c'est beau là c'est pas beau à verser
s'effacer l'art moderne peut-être
philharmonia je comprends pas non plus
mais c'est peut-être ça doit sécher
prend enfin sa plus grosse au sketch des
inconnus
oui même écran un pinceau il balance
vrai je faisais un pigeon prévenu effet
après il écrit que 50000 euros
du coup ça me fait un peu penser à ça
mais du coup peut-être que les échecs
c'est comme la force à celui-là dont
l'arrêté intéressant ici chèques étaient
imprécis intéressant j'aurai un présent
on attend le nouveau grand artiste ou en
l'art est devenu complètement ridicule
des échecs au site les x suivent la tête
copains là dessus mais ça c'est un peu
dommage mais donc du coup la donne cinq
ans de devis d'espérance de vie à ce
truc là et après c'est mort mais après
on fera des échecs 960 et du bullet que
allez va donc peut-être reviendra aux
échecs de sa saison 1966 du c905 light
fera son come back ou du rapide n'ont
même pas même pas non rapide c'est non
même pas mécénat 64,6 france et
l'allemagne puis elles ont d'autres sens
oui mais enfin 959
enfin il veut interdire cette pollution
elle va beaucoup plus loin certes cette
position serait combinant interdite note
une étude non d'ailleurs là le truc dont
vous voulez parler on peut le faire la
wii pendant l'été les gens qui posent
des questions oui vous allez faire quoi
ce soir et jusqu'à quelle heure on va un
peu discuté jusqu'à 21h30 pendant une
heure moment-là déchets depuis mai un
truc pas trop dans l'action fait en
train de dire des trucs mais du coup
c'est alors on part en chrono fois ses
excuses en fait on l'a eu un petit peu
mais ouais non mais n'hésitez pas à
réagir dans le tchat plus vous poser des
questions plus ça peut être intéressant
interactif vous n'êtes pas d'accord
c'est bien vers d'autres points de vue
avant mais on n'est pas là avec une
vérité absolue
quand je vous dis enfin la nuit à la
vérité absolue faire injure de facto
mais nous on fait juste notre point de
vue et c'est vrai que c'est devenu un
peu enfin cesser de pire en pire en fait
c'est ça le truc c'est que c'est de pire
en pire
j'invoque on joue c'est souvent quand
même ok on verra peut-être joué la force
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut montrer le truc
que la femme le sporting est chaud
connexion et vas y que pas montré ok
donc genre le genre d'idées qui doivent
faire mon amour préparé pendant pas loin
le plus pauvre catherine gagner quoi ok
de 4 5 3 des 6 des quatre bouffe bouffe
kiev 6 cas et c'est 3 à 6 nash d'or est
ok ce qui se passe c'est que vlad voyez
une partie de larsen parti n'a remporté
tous les bus aux couleurs d'une petite
vente de la noce d'or relativement
inoffensive auquel énorme à jouer sa vie
c'était en a les genres fawcett
peut-être petit 3
peut-être canada cpac ice3 direct dames
la d23 ok ben t'as raison en fait mais
aux québécois qui encensent position ce
que vlad avait remarqué et tout le monde
est à bon niveau c'est que les blancs ce
qu'ils aimeraient s'y installent un
cavalier ici c'est une bonne case 1
toujours en serre cahier sur la 5eme
branger proche du rhône heures c'est
super bien prennent des gloires ont
toujours joué j'ai six contrôles la case
et est en fait pas trop de problèmes
pour les rares quoi ils vont se
développer avec le fond de fils tokyo
lilas ou en 17 c 5e peut-être rb5 b4
attaqué ce cas va lire et met la
pression au centre et une position tout
à fait jouable donc fait cai contrôler
la case de 4 quelques mains il défend
enfin mais ok donc ça on s'appuie
nombreuses décennies que c'est censé
être ok pour les noirs est ok ce qui se
passe dans la partie great choc maxime
c'est qu'ils commencent parfois aux
trois dons qui peut préparer l' attaque
anglaise sur rossi 6e 5
ensuite les l'enjeu f3 dam des deux
grands rock puis on peut renvoyer g4 g5
le pion à chez nous sommes aussi de
faire j'ai six casser la structure pions
le roi qui sera peut-être faible et il
ya du jeu dans sa double tranchant
peut-être un peu émue pour les blancs
bref je vous ils s'attendaient ok j'ai
cassé le cou à la mode à haut niveau ce
qui se passe c'est que les blancs
général bons soient ils font pousser un
le mans répète les coûts on a déjà vu
des nuls comme ça notamment mcshane
quand nakamura je crois le millionnaire
chess une fois et pourquoi pas l'autre
coup pour jouissif ou g5
ils surent h6 en général les blancs
pouech 4 mai nord continue par gilles
5-fu g3 fou g7 dont invoqué les pions
sont les pions là sont un peu avancé
parfois saône 10 et 2 h 4 avec les
blancs mais théoriquement ça va bien
pour les noirs juste un truc à savoir
ici un coût qui peut sembler logique et
qui est très très mauvaise et f3 on dit
tiens je fais ma chaîne de pions le
problème c'est qu'après cabello 3 d'un
bouge où il ya icade
on perd une pièce puisque si damas
emprise doivent ok fourchette et on tend
la main
donc non je continue à jouer donc bloqué
ici je crois que je h3 que je faisais
que je détruirai qu'alliée de 58 il ya
beaucoup de théories mais théoriquement
c'est ok pour les noirs même kasparov a
déjà joué ça à l'époque
dans certaines parties des années 90 ok
l'idée de l'add on revient maintenant
bon bah ils en reviennent lequel il n'a
plus rien à faire ici il va juste se
prendre des tempos dessus donc on a une
position normale de nageurs fait que ce
truc en plus qui est ce que ça monte à
joue pas dur à dire à vue de nez on
souvent ça avantage quand même les noirs
l'éventail shikata par 6 à 1 et à pâques
les jeunes la plupart du temps ça va
quand même être mieux pour les noirs on
n'aura plus sa maison qui lui disaient
de transposer dans le monde de l'art
scène qu'on a vu et donc toute la
subtilité vient là parce qu'après ce
genre de coups donc je sais plus
exactement salikou dans l'ordre de coups
un petit but de dams et sonnerie nokia
temps mais peu importe
en tout cas à contenir le genre position
peut-être le fond des deux mais peu
importe ok maintenant très difficile
pour un adieu g6 parce que on a provoqué
six mois il va être en l'air donc on ne
peut plus faire g6 on est beaucoup plus
embêtés avec les noirs pour mettre en
place les pièces et
et au final j'ai tout cas c'est très
bien même gagnant de cette partie juste
maxime et défend de manière très tenace
il est arrivé le piège après en finale
attendue des menus l'avait trouvé le
demi point mais ok il faut maintenant on
arrivé à ce degré là de préparation à
venir maintenant je suis là c'est juste
qu'il est très très fier cette nouveauté
est l'une des ses plus belles nouveautés
depuis plusieurs années parce que c'est
très fin bah oui c'est très fin en soi
mais en fait ils voient aussi un autre
problème c'est que c'est pas du tout
accessible
11h05 les lattoises accessible à moi
encore huit immenses accessible quand
même et c'est juste que je pense pas
forcément mais je peux réussir à
comprendre que le kw/h si si si oui mais
c'est ça j'ai mes mauvais mais de là à
comprendre que c'est en gardant la
partie 2
tombé ce genre tish parce que c'est
comme ça que tu le trouves et que tu a
incorporé h6 tout ça bon dans ces cas là
ça devient beau mais ça devient de l'art
qui est quand même un peu trop
sophistiqué lucquois radieux et en plus
ça ne réussit rien non certainement
d'autres schémas jouer oui oui c'est à
dire car je pense maintenant qu'une fois
ci on rejoue sa maxime quoi il va juste
par joe lynch emma exactement d'affaires
de 6 ou yves jacques et 17 blessés ce à
un coût que sa joie mais y'a pas
meilleur jeu pour les noirs mais arrêtez
ça tout le truc c'est que voici que
c'était beau mais que ça réfuté
fondamental dans le truc ça resterait
même dans les bouquins tout ça on
l'apprendra aux gens et aurait quand
même fait un truc qui même s'il n'est
pas très accessible de base sera utile à
tout le monde serait utile avion puis
deviendra obligatoire mais je dirais ben
tiens tu vois un peu quand les aventures
tayev que vlad montré dans l'espagnol où
il montrait la voie en dessous ça les
gens s'en rappellent les mêmes genres
trente ans après tu remontes 21 mai
qu'un mec un jour qu'un mec qui a montré
ça et surtout réduit qu'avec l'âge les
quintés tu rêves de tomber machin là le
truc en fait c'est que ça joue sur une
partie sera plus jamais jouer parce que
du coup plus personne va tomber dedans
du coup ça tombe immédiatement dans les
oubliettes ne sert que tu allais 500
personnes qui sont vraiment intéressés
par l'échec de haut niveau où je sais
pas peut-être juin 2000 dans mon jeu pac
man c'est exactement de personnes mais
ça va être plus que 3 4 milles de toute
façon que j'exagère en disant 500 mais
quand je dis 4000 j'exagère pied de
l'autre côté c'est 4000 personnes tu as
peut-être 10% des gens qui essaient de
se poser la question pourquoi donc en
gros tu trouve quand même un truc qui
est assez beau mais qui est accessible
en réalité tête à 400 ou 300 personnes
dans le monde
ce qui était un peu léger quand tu sais
le nombre d'heures que tu dois passer
pour trouver ça mais bon ce qui a changé
parce qu'à l'époque alain docq époque ça
intéressait beaucoup plus de gens c'est
quelque part plus accessible ce que s'il
y avait moins c'était mon ordinateur est
comme disait comme père et puis surtout
le truc c'est que si tu trouves une
bonne nouveauté du col à replacer savait
pas l'info qui certes n'a pas internet
mais je voulais même réfuté une
ouverture pendant dix ans et la
nouveauté non mais en fait tu veux une
partie parce que notre courant avait
alors joué à tous leurs joueurs au
québec une fois été un informateur six
mois plus tard mais au pire quoi et puis
tu réfutait le truc quand même pendant
un certains nombres temporairement ses
terres et futée et on attendait
peut-être la repro la con tre réfutation
qu'un mec un jour trouverez d'autres
apprécient retombe dans la vieille dame
semble pourquoi il a joué ça et j'en
suis il ya cette idée là et tout alors
que là je sais pas tout stockfisch
dix minutes après la très belle idée
mais je te revient futon 45 secondes et
cage et c'est ça le problème en fait et
c'est un gros pot à la fois en discute
avec bats et enfin je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec lui c'est un très gros
coup à la fête
non maintenant une tonne de travail pour
un résultat qui attend une fois maximum
et ouais frustrant quelque part là
frustrant pour les joies est frustrant
pour les fans comme nous aussi nous
n'avançons un peu comme des comme des
fans et c'est un peu frustrant aussi
alors on va dire le chat hugo trouve que
les échecs ont changé mais pas forcément
mal en tout cas à moindre niveau là où
il y a de la prépa mais pas trop non
plus trouve ça un peu près pas sûr que
non mais évidemment c'est plus
accessible maintenant pour le niveau a
ses amateurs de se préparer et de parce
qu'en fait avant qu'il fallait acheter
des livres et comprendre par soi-même
tout ce qui se passe maintenant ok
l'ordi va beaucoup aider une tonne de
données même rec les vidéos tout ça ça
va être forcément moins généreux et les
voilà donc en fait oui pour le peut-être
la compréhension du jour plus à ma place
n'est pas vain d'en donner ce que
l'intérêt conservateur s'est pas non
plus de gagner ce que j'étais préparé
puisque tu connais des ouvertures mais
plutôt parce que tu comprend le jeu
ouais mais bon quelques rares hockey et
comprend deux ouvertures ça peut t'aider
à comprendre le jeu mais faut dire que
sa fin c'est pas pareil c'est plus
intéressant d'être assis devant une
position que t'as jamais vu et d'essayer
de conceptualiser le truc est comme ses
rivales de faire de la fhp désert de la
philosophie en fait non mais en fait il
que la science a marché pareil à
l'époque c'est ce qu'ils pensent et
philosophiquement même einstein tout ça
et puis c'est ya du coup ça doit être
comme ça ça va être comme ça il trouvé
comme ça alors primo nous dit que c'est
les amis le blanc n'ont pas le temps de
genève 3 avant comme dans ce négoce
l'avs tu parles au 6e coups bas mais
j'ai eu peur oui oui donc sa série au
ricoh s'il jouerait pas de lasser la
neige d'or font qu'il ya plein plein de
coups possibles jamais voulez pas vous
prendre du kg kf3 possible rouages 3 ou
h 3 bien sûr et ça réduit les choix des
martyrs sur iphone aussi soit il faut le
après s'ils veulent jouer une petite
variante je crois que d'un v6 impossible
ce qui ne l'est pas sur [ __ ] en mai
mais look et f3 au lycée un coup jouable
après juste on s'enlève des options par
rapport à sous le train dans le sens où
des fois les gants vos crèmes joseph 4
en 1 ou des fois non pas de champion est
fait on fait rage 3 et 4 par exemple
ouais moi j'ai déjà joué des parties
comme ça en fait forme sur cinq
cavaliers la foux je ne sais pas ce
n'est pas faux c'est la faulx 6 h 30
quai pas le bon coup cf 31 mai l'idée
pendant sur cavaliers là on balance j4h
6 dan des deux baies san roque
ok ça c'est jouable jouable jeu
compliqué d'ailleurs voilà c'est
compliqué j'avais gagné une partie assez
facilement sur un truc que je
connaissais en fait mais faute des noirs
c'était ça ça ok là ils peuvent prendre
ce pouvoir regagner celui-là est donc ok
on attaque suis là et va devoir repartir
mais en fait le jeu souffre de ce côté
et non pas fini le développement ce peut
être dangereux pour eux on a toujours f4
qui peut rêver couvre tour avec se
ressentent c'est un peu dangereux et
wallin on joue à 5 donc des champions
j'étais fou b5 et la grave faute des
noirs compris entre 4 en fait trop mais
qui continue marie d un lancer à quatre
ont un celui-là il valait un peu à des
clients 1
pas très bien placé on sera alors sortir
plus tard on verra mais un gros combat
parce que les pièces blanches sont
actives et attention ce fou ce qui se
passe qui est dangereux icloud cavaliers
et donc la grosse menace c'est fou les
six écailles c'est cette voie là est ok
ce qui s'était passé dans la partie où
elle n' en effet ça a mal joué dame là
ça peut paraître une bonne idée ans
dwayne j'ai fait refaire prend et sur
dame frange ramène aux cavaliers mais le
problème c'est qu'on a secoué
intermédiaires et sur dame très logique
cublac fin de la partie ok donc derrière
s'était rendu compte de ça il y avait eu
je crois qu'il est ici merveille le
problème des noirs pour être tout est
ouvert
on va se faire et montrer avec ff iv la
turquie va arriver je crois que j'ai
joué dans le cadre dans la partie mon
boss de prendre le purin ya le clouage
on associe qualité 7 puisque la dame
seule à défendre mais pourra plus
défendre la tour
ok bref on a su de la partie pas
forcément très intéressante donc ok
juste pour dire f3 très possible mais tu
t'emmerdes et la souplesse quelque temps
après les blancs que je vais faut 2 les
manceaux jouent et h3 devant que je j'ai
trois bons jeux à 4 j'ai eu ma news qui
a joué à troyes ce que je fous g5 la
grande ligne comme à l'époque il ya même
eu comme ils s'appellent barthel de le
croate dont maître polonais qui veut
très souvent que kelly b3 ici d'une
redite ski h4 muscade vous dégagez
partout au québec que c'était même
parfum c'était pas ça à l'air très moche
faire c'est moi ce que sap erp athènes
pas en fait bongo qui est plein de lui
faire comment à tour j'ai un projet une
finale très réputation de l'aïd c'est
une finale
donc oui oui plein de trucs du coup
plein plein plein plein d'options
d'options différentes alors
ainsi chaque boulette gros lard et ce
que j'ai fais peut-être une erreur dans
le titre possible de titres
le titre de la vidéo j'ai voulu changer
de titre ce qui est inutile diboula de
brawl mais en fait c'est peut-être je me
suis planté
non mais au pire en pire puis on peut
faire quelques bulles est si l'audience
s ils veulent des bulles elle est mon
nom est reparti au gmi partie parce que
je n'ai pas exactement
je pensais que je pensais regarder
norwich est semée donc quand on avait
annoncé le 7 et le plan mais les partis
il ya plus de partir et les parties
finissent donc en fait le plan de base
un peu vous switchez le switch est mal
fin malheureusement il est donc attendu
notre réponse
bonjour m des gens vraiment dur
boulaud qui nous demandent pourquoi
cette vidéo pourquoi les questions non
mais en fait chaque jeudi ont fait un
petit un petit truc donc c'est une
dernière c'était un tournoi tous les
mois dans la façon dont compenser
éventuellement réorganiser un tournoi
peut-être de 960 ou quoi m'ont séduit
aussi ok quitte à être là pourquoi pas
discuter échec
normalement quand on vous disait il y
avait le droit de chasse encore en
baisse mais le plan a en fait mais enfin
on pensait que les parsis durera pour
élever une finale pendant un moulinet
des belles parties en fait aujourd'hui
en fait que des nuls et du coup tf1 +
championnats d'europe hier pourquoi pas
moi ce qui joue encore alors championnat
d'europe ailleurs
ok on peut viser la partie de job à
temps c'est une finale intéressante
celle là je pense qu'elle est gagnante
si tu as réussi à éloigner le roi jean
fisam ans non mais tu peux le pâté et
tonneaux j'ai dit plus tu manges wayne
évoqué faut le passer mais c'est dans le
livre de touretski ce look est donc on
pour les plus amateurs d'entre vous en
général c'est des finales gagnante pour
les blancs côtoient une pièce de plus on
mange les pions et ont fait dame là le
gros problème des blancs c'est que ce
pion pas ch va atterrir sur une case
noire comme un fou de cases blanches et
si le roi noir est dans le coin
ici ils veulent stopper on pourra rien
faire je peux montrer par exemple un
couloir droit mais si je crois que c'est
un ok je vous montre par exemple il part
par la botte à clou
même si on attaquait par oui non mais
n'importe qui il va chez lui là bas
ok maintenant on peut plus jamais gagner
simplement il va rester là on va là
c'est d'avancer d'autres pions on avance
on avance à 9 ans il va rester là et
puis puis s'en fiche complète il bouge
toi et quand on fera échec pour
l'éloigner il va bien sûr pas de
coopératif à nous laisser faire dame
il va venir ici si on veut continuer à
avancer en tous cas pas tout ce que je
dis souvent quand explique sa frappe
c'est que comme on peut pas contrôler la
case noire le roi va forcément aller
quand il sort sur une case blanche
et puis on pourra jamais empêcher de
revenir en route du rhum sur une case
donc sa série gagnante d'un footing noir
puisque là où le tri de fond b2c finit
donc là c'est le gros problème actuel de
l'obsession donc
d'arriver à prendre les deux pions sans
que le roi de perse ne puisse revenir et
alors il est en train de faire un truc
pas mal c'est que si le roi s'éloigne
trop verbe et deux dans ce cas là n'a
pas forcément le temps de revenir on
peut éventuellement le pied pas de
purger cinq ce serait dur de mémoire en
fou qui le path
ouais donc le bien sûr il faut pas
croire c'est nul dans tous les cas s'il
a dans cette position c'est de bien
n'existait pas vous serez le pion le roi
noir n'est pas dans le carré alors
sommes un peu par voler donc on ne peut
pas il ne peut pas arriver ensuite
non ce à quoi donc poussé vous faites
dames c'est pas nul automatique du tout
c'est nul si le roi l'a donc un plan de
gains possibles
c'est ça c'est de bloquer le roi vite
venir prendre ou alors et s'il met ce
roi dans un impact par exemple le roi
noir ici le roi blanc reviendraient là
comme ça et on joue faux b3
soeurs-noires johnny sera obligé de
faire j'ai quatre on va prendre
ils poussent leur truc ok bien c'est
fini parce que je trouvais 3 viendrait
sur cette diagonale contre le pion et
nous on aura une autoroute devant nous
et on ira faire d'hommes
donc en gros l'idée c'est de combiner
les deux c'est que si le roi s'éloigne
trop de ce côté là normalement doit
pouvoir essayer de gagner parce qu'on
attend de prendre les pions sur les
cours enfin encore que ok il faut
calculer tout cas c'est souvent à la
casse près et du coup l'autre idée c'est
de cette sphère se battent se bat et
donc une erreur
cumulant les deux choses normalement ne
peut réussir à gagner mais c'est hyper
difficile
ok nos possibilités aussi si le roi noir
revient de ce côté si on regarde le
foutoir diagonale je sais pas par là on
bloque ses cases soit le temps de
prendre les deux derniers leur là aussi
on le bloque suivante si c'est pas gagné
cette élection
noir j'ai plus avancé parce qu'on lui
fait une barrière en fait le lien entre
le sort et ça et le roi qui serait ici
contrôler tout ça je suis pas du tout
sûr de rien on peut vérifier en fait ça
de livres mail gmail 9,1 des pièces
aussi pièce hockey et à bonal imhof
on va dire ça tout de suite
dont le talent n'est même pas mal pour
toute position de six pièces il vous dit
tout de suite c'est nul ça gagne premier
de couleur donc blanc roi des six noms
arabes et 4 blancs five set blanc pions
h3 bras en signe d'après na li maps est
nul car à cinq enseignes colonna après
ok c'est peut-être faut pas trop se
tromper car je sais pas si leur hobby 4
était hélas ces gagnants vous en laisse
et en c3 ok une renault attend bidos
gagnerait dès qu'il y ait des gens ces
trois nuls mais or il ya moyen de jouer
longtemps essayé de piéger l'adversaire
en finale intéressante on va voir on va
succinct port en fil rouge peut-être
signe si mauvaise escient arrive à
piéger son adversaire si injuste qui
jouent encore à part cette porte et non
pas trop ok il ya la partie de what do
ba tan un survol je les croise et un peu
plus loin
sûrement tokyo arrive à quai jobez va
très intéressant
pour le team parce que c'est une tuerie
que les gens ne voient lé bon coin
c'était juste pour avoir une réponse à
une réponse théorique au truc une lettre
aux demandes
oui oui c'était pour moi ok j'en vois tu
as ils essayent de reuze demeure donc
besoin alors attends attends en avant de
la revendre ouvert jo bats pas tu l'as
fait des queues se souvient que des noms
je suis entre amis ont du goût suroît c3
il veut faire droit à 5 et / ou à ses
5es de fer aura trois oui bien sûr
grosses sautes de feu roi c'est juste
pour montrer que si on ferra c'est
justement là on arrive dans l'idée dont
on parle et on parlait le roi n'a plus
de gaz n'est obligé de faire j'ai quatre
qui on prend à trois pouces et 6 mai on
vous entre lâche 1 et le roi ne peut pas
s'envoler vers le pion et donc c'est
gagné on aimerait avoir commencé avant
cela recommence avance alors cette
partie femmes ouais je bave intéressant
qui est très très mal conçu le tournoi
hockey dehors peut-être le chat avant on
parle de job après le ciel qu'il ya deux
mondes celui des pros et les amateurs
probable la théorie est connu a assimilé
par les pros la plupart des amateurs
sont à des années lumière de cette
connaissance donc encore beaucoup de
plaisir à jouer
oui non c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est sur
les riques après un sport il se
modifient souvent en fonction des pros
par exemple le hawk eye au tennis ça
n'existe que dans les trois
professionnels et quelque part c'est lui
tout un professionnel que les gens
regardent loïc si les participants
professionnels sont pas très
intéressantes
au final c'est devant l'ag pour les
sponsors et pour le public mais j'ai
remarqué en tout cas c'est marrant dans
les échecs c'est que souvent donc pas
avec des joueurs que tu as quand à des
élèves à découvrir tout cela il ya en
fait très peu le voir qu'ils regardent
vraiment les parties par plaisir et
regarde pour ce qui est des nouveautés
ou des trucs comme ça mais c'est rare de
voir des amateurs qu'ils ont je vais
passer mon après midi devant devant le
toit de norvège par exemple pas tu vois
bien dans les chiffres sur le nombre de
gens connectés sur les liens mais le
problème c'est que c'est très très long
cours de regarder une partie tout peut
être autre chose à faire ta journée tu
peux pas d'accord et puis même si tu
bosses pas tu peux aller à la plage tu
peux de la rivière tennis tu peux je
sais pas tu fais ce que tu veux voir des
pas d'avoir un verre enfin peu importe
et là les partis qui vers 6h intense et
dur de fiches de la zone tu peux faire
des sauts de puce souvent moi même ce
que je fais je regarde un peu
l'ouverture après c'est autre chose
revient voir tiens comment aller en âge
remarque que même nous on était plus
passionnés enfin on sera plus passionnés
demain devant wawrinka murray que oui
enfin on est capable de regagner par une
guerre murray pendant trois heures
d'affilée
du coup ça y est un problème non mais
c'est à dire ça comme ça c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant pour toi une caméra que
eux
et toi tu es plutôt amateur d'échecs de
base
j'aime bien le jeu lui-même toi c'est
qu'il ya un problème à belladères fois
que j'étais vraiment été scotché devant
devant un événement d'échec c'était
c'était comme kasparov a joué contre les
américains c'était sympa en blitz a donc
entre nakamura psoe et caruana toute l
année dernière et auquel a le même toit
juste à barcelone un resto moment là on
avait mis on a émis la télé avec le
câble hdmi et tout pour garder toute la
soirée
et et du monde et tout juste à fond mais
dans le rôle supporters en fait même
plus que dans le rôle amateurs enfin
nombre d'amateurs de chaque aussi tu me
dire mais je voulais qu'il soit
ouais c'est l'info que j'étais vraiment
à fond à fond devant une partie l'avons
fait il ya aussi eu le départage de
karine karine ne t'ai pas forcément bon
mais je reviendrai mais en fait même
assez sympa non non ça c'était cool sans
plusieurs de la tension il y avait un
truc comme ça laisse assez rare en fait
mais c'est dans le tie-break une
nouvelle fois c'était pas les partis
disent ok après peut-être l'a12 s'il y
avait vraiment la douille s'est passé on
songe vous indique où est-ce que gerda
12,6 carrés qu'ils menaient encore d'un
point à 108 rue quelque chose comme
kramnik les quoi par exemple où les
dernières rondes karpov et kasparov à
l'époque sunnite soins sur l'honnêteté
encore récent je me régale à suivre les
retransmissions ouais mais bon ça il ya
des jeux enfin comme je dis à deux trois
quatre mille personnes qui regardent
mais c'est très très peu mais tous que
tu regardes six heures de film c'est
très possible
non bien si tu le fais pas c'est pas un
reproche c'est juste une question pour
le pied ni même à 2006 j'avais eu qu'à
5/10 fiscal droit théorique vous fait
envie
s'il ya une finale de curieux non mais
attention enfin le genre est tous
humains et et puis on peut faire des
fautes
et de deux tu joues tu es fatigué tu
oublies un truc funéraire enfin pas
parce que c'était le théorique qui aura
nul au kenya par la partie joe bhavan
roule en parler parce qu'il ya très très
mal commencé le tournoi il avait un sur
trois avec deux défaites contre des
joueurs moins forts que lui un autour de
1500 et 2000 400 dans ce cas c'est rare
quand j'aurai pu 2007 il ya eu pas mal
en plus à signaler que je bave arrive
sûrement un peu sur les rotules puis
sillage le top 12 avant genre le top-12
fini ça je suis plus que le 28 je crois
28 mai le 29 jamais voyagé je crois que
ça jouer le 30 ou 31 no 38 je pense donc
donc ouais tu joues en ce parti est
urgent ou direct donc pas évident et qui
depuis nous fait une énorme montalat
donc la main sur trois victoires on d'un
des patrons d'edf et 33 et de kelly
gagnon l'acadienne à s'incliner 6 ghana
ça de gagné 8 guinée la nappe je pense
ok donc ça lui fait ça lui fait sept
points comptent donc il peut il peut
même finir champion des rois princes qui
continue à ce rythme aujourd'hui a été
très impressionnant donc là les noirs
ils commencent pour une housse l'avre
hockey et gavin jones
ok il aime je sais pas si c'est vrai je
vais beaucoup aux quatre avec des
systèmes par avec des petites variantes
mais il connaît bien ses trucs ni la
fatigue est dangereux c'est calcule bien
il est bon tactics tu donnes initiative
il peut te rouler dessus et est ok donc
là il commence par cette vente un peu
d'anglais des français dans ok je vais à
jouba il prend le pion d'être qui le
rendra plus tard même temps comme il a
déjà son plan c6 éventuellement il peut
avoir du bessin qui va qui va aider à
soutenir
donc pourquoi pas après si les noirs
veulent jouer très solide
ça peut être où les parties de celle
qu'on a vue autant en norvège entre sow
et maxime tu juges ici c'est quand même
si ce genre de trucs on a juste à la il
a levé 3 dont il est actionnaire régis
et 5 très solide on peut aussi jouer des
poings sur b3 on peut aussi jouer des
français et ses 5 qu'est ce que c'est
que ça en est revenue ce pardon je sais
pas si plus qu'à sauter mais de saborder
oui sous les phares g6 et solide b3
n'est pas forcément une que je montrais
mais les blancs peugeot etc prend des
mais ça c'est symétrique que je donne
des trois cliniques mais ok bref hockey
jéhovah
fidèle à son style dynamique et actif à
y prendre un pion ils vont au combat
foulée fou j'ai deux caïds et sat
donc ma foi pourquoi pas lui qui avait
plutôt bien placé pour deux raisons il
peut venir ici défendre et aussi il est
éventuellement que c'est aux 5
je voulais donc peut-être une sorte de
structure sicilienne inversé est ok
cavalia trois attaques le pion de 5
alors peut-être que vous vous demandez
pourquoi pas b5 j'ai l'impression que
déjà qui est des quatrains soucie
beaucoup de mal à s'inverser les
processus parce qu'apres en bessin à
quoi est ce qu'on prend c'est 6
donc non en fait voilà aussi simple que
ça donc qui est à trois de cinq
ok la paperie direct vous pourrez
peut-être mais je pense qu'il était
peut-être récupérer qu'à y prend part
eux quatre ils y voient jeunes cavaliers
une option à 4 1 peut pas mal placée ce
qui me bloque la des ménages du fou
surtout s'apprennent d'anjou est simple
un truc comme ça wasquehalienne si si
vous bien renforcés donc c'est toujours
pas mal en fait un contre 1.2 kg est
aussi derrière être un pion là en fait
ça lui réduit vraiment ça ça parait il a
des jumelles il déjà il ya puis on sait
si spacek qui le gêne un peu et là je ne
vois plus rien qu'est ce que c'est que
ça donc ok d'homs et on peut comprendre
la vie non je tire sur celui qui veut
devenir de bons il viendra pas devant
toi mais la contrepartie c'est que
bah durable et saïdi qui est des quatre
stades soucis mais il ya plus le pion
donc voilà ça change chaque coup font
remettre en question ce qui se passe
c'est pas parce qu'une fois que ça
marchait pas que ce sera du coup la
roque a dit m aeternam le cas brock
développement b3 ok très thématique un
contingent restructure on peut le voir
dans les catalanes en pleine ouverture
on casse le mur et on ouvre les pièces
parce qu'on est mieux développer avec
les blancs représentent les nombrils pur
ont défendu machin tu fais tu fais d'une
pierre deux coups en plus que tu m'as se
développer le four b2 et de réattaquer
le pur et 5 ta le pion c'est risqué dans
la visée de l'ada mauricie en live s'ils
fumaient l'oeuf
du coup je me situe là mais me situe là
le pion c4 s'il prend b3 approuvé trois
mon avis même tout près de moi c'est
d'abord intermédiaire ils savent à
craindre un point noir de la tour sera t
qui lui sera attaqué par clouage lui
sera attaqué et on pourra reprendre
l'ibook ça fait trop troubles mc5 ok se
développe très bien
hélas assez bien joué parce qu'en fait
ils laissent le blanc le son de
production bkc 4 et puis après ils
poussent donc en fait quelque part ça
bloque ce sera ça souligne que le
cavalier mal placé objet de retour en b1
qui sera très mal passé par rapport au
cahier des 4 et opium et carnac qui
bloque les cases à trois essais trois
dans le côté la dame t'as plus sur ces 6
oui donc elle est bloquée par le pion
ces cas donc sa position est un peu
moins bonne
et là il a dans l'idée de jouer deux cas
c'est ce qu'il faut au prochain donc
fabien et il veut jouer industrie
dynamique et essayer d'installer ce pion
au centre éventuellement s'il l'a dont
il a bien calculé besoin fait le fait de
jouer le 4 on peut se dire ok mais le
cuir est perdu quand j'attaque une fois
getac deux fois jeté trois fois n'écris
pas des affaires 5 et voilà donc ça a
l'air perdu mais il avait bien calculé
en fait on quand il est entré là dedans
il joue ce coup intermédiaire bien jouer
avec la tourner en coin donc fou b2
obligatoire et câblées et qu'elle est
c'est simple donc il défend donc ok il
défend une fois de moins le truc c'est
que la dame doit à la fois défendre et
attaquer ici
donc elle doit être en surcharge ce qui
se passe si les blancs prennent près une
prennent
bon vous prenez pas ici parce que vous
prenez paris chaque prenez d'abord en b
2-1 sur dame prendre de but ni sur dame
cinq échecs double attaque
vous avez 2007 et non les jeunes c'est
pour de savorgnan il faut toujours le
calcul jusqu'au bout les vingt et un
faux pas dire à quel point le 4 c'est
fini il faut toujours essayer de voir le
coup en plus de toutes atteint donc en
fait je veux pas c'est que quand tu es à
haut niveau après le court puis ce sont
aux coudes estime manquer combien de
parler comme ça où tu quelques dents de
scie coup et que ça tienne une pointe de
nourriture se fait donc il faut toujours
il faut toujours voir jusqu'au bout donc
on en est un
on va être que je suis un truc mal ou un
objet de chacun je rembobine auxquels
fait trop le qu'est ce que c'est que ça
mais ces scènes de we mais en fait il
faut turbine ici un record des
affréteurs honorine pareil mais non mais
si si si malin ça valait donc il attend
janvier comme ça peut-être un truc qu'on
aime parce que nous ne faisons qu il
apprit le métier
un nom qui prend b2 français ces chocs
du coup il faut toujours pouvoir
jusqu'au bout bien bien par les pontes
du pur rock le rock ok intéressants mais
ils sont à l'abri des trois prises prise
leur attention est une question quand on
crache sa ba oui on le sait 3 je suis
dit ça pour l'instant je peux répondre
après applicast pour le fou dans
l'impression et certains il faut le
montrer
oui mais en enrôlant bobigny n'est ce
pas grave tu es pressé non tu attends
que ma grand mère ok dans le souci voilà
ce fou doit être défendue par l'adam
donc des gens menace de prendre ça et
dévier la dame deuxième souci donc on se
dit ok je veux ramener quelque part bon
toutes les cases sont attaqués et
éventuellement ici bon là c'est là un
peu match mais bon peut-être sa perte à
sion le champ comme simplement je pense
que rien que s'accroître
c'est mon choix je crois je sais pas
bref sa décision at war 3 au 6 novembre
[Musique]
mais en fait je dis pas forcément oui
non
mais du coup il écrit que jusqu'au bout
ok parce que sur dame prend elle sera
pas protégé ici on va [ __ ] mais deux
échecs et vis-à-vis et les rêves en
cadeau il me fou prend b2 voici puisque
lequel nous pouvons pas vous les lattois
renferme donc en fait ça gagne notable
de burton après ok même choix je crois
va l'air sympa ou simplement une crise
est peut-être de faire 2006 de melun a
peut-être même il m'a t on vers un oui
mais regarde ses entraîneurs parents du
retour à domicile ce tarif 6 ou prend
des quatre lots thématiques aussi plus
demain enfin plus de défense ok donc
plein de trucs sympa donc je rembobine
désolé on va la pression finale et je
vais revenir en arrière et je le
retrouve sa position
on en était à ce truc lindon qui l'a pas
pris h cette île 9 détroit dans le tchat
ce qu'on nous dit à des digues mise
looking for what extent analyse et le
kevin dans la tente de l'analyse de
l'exclusion bonjour qu'est s'est
autosaisi six poèmes chicago il est très
sympa mais je pense que c'est à quoi la
nuit de l'exclusion
je sais pas peut-être tu peux le dire
aux autres failles ici si tu payes tu
peux tu peux écrire en anglais
le canola thing il part en france a
vraiment très sympa en plus non mais ça
j'en doute toi tu sais qu'on dit que si
t'as pas de sou sur ton chasse c'est que
ton style c'est de la merde c'est un
patron absolu du truc du coup je regarde
un peu l'autre si même à domicile
allez l'om sur intéressant d'analyser
des parties de d1 belge à partir
d'octobre pour loi madère
bah franchement on peut faire mal et
jeudi toute façon ces extreme un peu
libre
donc si vous jouer des parties qui vous
semble sympa pourquoi pas nous les
envoyer et on les regarde avec vous on
peut peut-être me regarder en amont
avoir un automne plutôt que cela en fait
on découvre et on est d'une bêtise sur
une variante wef d'un pont près par
clermont en vidéo si on est les bureaux
confère au long des couloirs mais si on
prépare en plus des stream serait mineur
et demi nous faudrait cinq heures de
préparation jours des journées de 40
heures ouais ouais on pourrait pas d'en
croquer des trois donc il pouvait pas
faire froid dans la zone pourra faire
une vidéo après on leur a bien reçu
voilà repérables et prend 1,4 fois h 3o
qui attaquent la tour
alors non il ya un truc qui mêlant
marrant je sais pas vraiment su
retourner ainsi on peut pas jouer sa
question
ok bon il faut prendre la dalle en toute
façon on reprend d'une tour je sais pas
laquelle on en dira el nahdha me prends
pas possible ou plans que ça ait on mate
et que faire parce qu'en fait on va
perdre ses deux tours gratos et on sera
toujours un fou pour une dame et c'est
là c'est trop quoi donc je crois que
c'est une belle variantes ouais c'est
venimeux autour des 1
on te prend bout dégage avec tes merde
on veut plus te voir dans vos kebabs dur
inspiré sort de rage
on était là à peu près prise fois je
crois donc tourner un fort c'est
peut-être pour ça c'était possible pas
moins dans l'esprit de ne pas faire
dessus surtout dire que la force soit la
burla un coup fantastique fantastic way
en étant désigné dans l'esprit plus
accueillir les voir sur le stream en
bullet soul à tour les gars c'est génial
rundle partir grosse partie d' attaque
il a fait 3 ma foi pourquoi pas
peut-être payé de jeu c'est parce c'est
jouable mais 2,3 en fait c'est pour
bloquer indéniable du fou qui avait plus
parce que l'on sent les noirs menaçants
comme ça donc ça me semble me vers le
ring on vous prendra me prend par
l'impression de la poterie périment si
on prend le cas de l omc vraiment les
cases blanches autour du roi est
notamment s'être cassé les deux mais tu
peux avoir des menaces avant les deux
tours preuve de avec la tour qui revient
à la fuite et du touret fermathe 1,96
euro sociaux ou même du tour pro f 2
dames des deux dames âgées de faim c'est
horrible on n'a pas développé lors du
turc et blanc tu peux
ce qui fait c'est qu'il se développe
donc ibai essaye de sortir ce cavalier
cette tour qui sont confirmées depuis un
moment donc je suis allée des deux a
presque y avait autre chose à faire ici
j'aime prendre b4 mais un minimum double
attaque
la mef 6 sur sa non pas faire dan d2
d'un point qui avait laissé trois sapins
je pense m
ok ok mais d'avoir david et de radio
tour des huit je pense à jamais au pire
même si on doit donner la dame compte
deux tours après on va devrez tour soit
colonnes d le montrer au cas où mais je
n'en suis à me prendre b4
qu'est ce qu'on appelle t-on preuve de
sa mère elle veut j'ai calculé ainsi
miroir prends tu repars ouais ok on peut
pas faire maths parce que la dame peut
revenir et elle défendra en a juste
donné un tour donc il faudrait récupérer
ça une fois c'est peut-être possible en
russie parce que disons les blancs envie
de sortir ce cavalier
donc ils peuvent aller 1-3 peut-être
l'autre l'autre option c'est adam d2
mais qui m'a l'air faible parce qu'il me
semble qu'à tours et fit alors je peux
faire graisser 3 à cause de super montré
est situé 120,04 attaque la dame va t'en
jetons ferme
on fait ça avant et on met de reprendre
un prof mais ok damned est faible il
faut faire comment se sortir mais mes
gars à trois points c'est qui atteint
3,2 kim en fait de tort quand même deux
hyper forte on fait dans ses positions
comment défendre mon histoire est fluide
on a juste gratté un pion pire et ouais
ça fait la première ligne quand on
regardait c'était la simple double
attaque de médecine si ça marche aussi
et kevin pensées vont tout moi dam des
deux est sûr d'un point qu'on a fait en
bas ce qui est pas bête
on peut juste pour intermédiaires ça
mange pas de pain ainsi dame prend on
prend lycée du coup on fait quoi faire
mais ça gagne aussi donc tout gagné
ok donc deux variantes pour gagner
celle-là peut-être plus expéditive ok
donc donc donc donc au moins étaient là
l'om prend beckham va pas du tout mais
on le sent quand on les a mais si ça
arrive avec une double attaque de toute
façon ça lui ment pas elle montre elle
serait permis accueille ces trois îles
et des deux peut-être la dernière option
pour the ghost days sera trop a
finalement je ne sais pas reda module ci
sait déjà c'est catastrophique ou pas
l'état va trouver des 3l matraque fraga
et c3 web 1 4 à 3 mais ok avoir
peut-être à 3,7 une option pour libérer
un peu toute cette aile dame mais où
cliquer les deux bombes pas trop
critiquer tu vois sont cueillies sort
dame ça tu défendes pions lecavalier
trop une case pourquoi pas maintenant on
peut essayer de ramener une tour ici
mais qui valait peut-être venir faire
une bonne case un peu couvrir ça au cas
où
et qui sait si un jour on peut venir là
ça peut être bien alors on nous demande
le chou mais il a vraiment défoncé dans
l'ouverture non c'est rare à ce niveau
là c'est rare même temps tu as et une
ouverture assez rare en fait pour le
coup enfin parce que ça arrange car elle
revenir un peu sur ceux dont la parler
avant certes dès qu'on tombe dans des
trucs un peu moins théorique comme la
des parties plus simple et plus sain et
tuent dans le coin et des parties plus
marrante en fait ouais et plus joli à
regarder en fait les deux là du coup ça
c'est cool regardez pas ça redevient pas
artistique est pas un parti nos
assiettes
regardez on les expédie à quoi nous
avons moins ça échange s'échange ces
échanges
et là on abat dur long qui peut perdre
contre des fratries 4 600 enfants
non mais mais normalement il gagne non
il est à fond et là pour le coup
je sais pas ce qu'il a fait pour
perturber gamine à ce point c'est quoi
le truc mes calculs peut-être les blancs
tu veux je sais pas peut-être ici après
aux cinq peut-être prendre ses pions
j'en sais rien d'être toléré au canada
c'est grave enfin la faudrait se plonger
un peu plus là je suis au volant quand
je parle de ces deux têtes de liste et
de descartes et chat un peu vers la
droite en fait pour pouvoir les voir et
ok peut-être ou alors fallait pas jouer
qu'il ya trois mois je sais pas non mais
bon c'est pareil comme très logique de
cette variante times a pas le truc de
15,5
parfois tu as l'autre option pour
innocent mais plus tard juste le système
compte la slave
tu peux pas je sais pas enfin
normalement tu peux quoi je me souviens
dans le livre de marie n'diaye on parle
de ça le grand maître roumain donc mais
à une marine qui avait fait trois tomes
sur l'anglais avec les blancs je pense à
c'était là sa recommandation vous faudra
vérifier un peu la théorie là-dessus
mais en tout cas oui très précis et
ambitieux de la part des lorsqu'il a
fait un allin fera une vidéo sur cette
partie ouais et donc on est et où au
moins est elle à peu près qui aimait
trois tours et 6 bon bah il veut doubler
il veut attaquer la faiblesse le roi
faible en fait c'est un truc cette cette
même position c'est à échanger les dames
ça serait beaucoup moins grave on
défendra juste avec une tour soit en
danger
peut-être on pourrait doubler on verra
lequel il pourrait commencer à venir
attaquer champions ce serait une autre
paire de manches
mais là le roi faible bien sûr un
facteur très important
pour pour juger la position c 5 ça
permet éventuellement peut-être de ses
banques et ses pions des 4 et de
stabiliser aussi la case des quatre
éventuellement pour le cavalier
peut-être un jour non tout aveu est là
ok sûrement la faute décisive même si je
penserai leur sont déjà plutôt très bien
mais peut-être c'est encore tenable avec
les blancs sont un jeu très précis
durant pratique mais c'est alain quoi me
to re 2 mais moi ça même temps j'étais
prête mais surtout renault peut-être
faire du fou g4 wave 3 heures comment et
après de crise yahoo ce we re place le
flou mais tu auras jeune dame qui va
menacer leur âge de aussi toute la bonne
compagnie avec comme un parti pris c'est
aussi l'heure c'est joli c'est ce que tu
as l'impression d'être un peu c'est très
joli 16 mai oui mais fou gkp donc du
coup donc pas super envie mais c'était
un peu forcé en fait de trucs bouquet
ga'lloween a fait tour c'est un métier
des principaux agents ce que je peux
faire là c'est bizarre tu peux emmener
ses phares f 4k et blanc ouais ouais là
je pense ça marche papillon prend
airways du bloc dans ça arrive des fois
cette idée neuve peut être parce que
moins sûr qu'à ce bar témoins faible et
le plomb est ce trop ton cerveau clie
contre les pieds adverses mais j'avais
des défenses comme ça payet dit enfin
100 sur f4 même pas je sais pas mais
j'ai déjà vu ça dans d'autres positions
je me rappelle plus lesquelles mais
prudent vous laisse peut-être des fois
quand le mec te met les pions g5
d'antalis assure f6 g5 et il menace de
faire tout reproche 7 et thomas des
renforts sur le roi tu fais h 5 puis on
prend pas sans accroc h7
oui c'est un thème aussi qu'on peut
avoir en poche d'eau sicilienne s'en
fait dans les chais venin bien sûr si
vous voyez ce qu'on parle mais souvent
c'est des positions clés n'ont joué que
6 des six petit rock les blancs ses
rangs des cfo de fautes trop f4 hoc et
un mois devant g4 g5 le khalife 6 doit
s'en aller
on placera davantage 5 on fait tout à
troyes et tours h3 pour aller mater les
noirs font h si certains noms pranger si
la dame doit bouger on bloque le pion h
et on s'en sert c'est un truc qui peut
transposable éventuellement donc
pourquoi pas ici c'est de défendre comme
ça après le truc peut-être convard des
soucis sur sur celui-là oui oui même si
je reçois une me permet de parler mais
je pense même pas raison de mentionner
qu'ils aient pas inquiet pas classique
est classique mais qui est pas forcément
super connu pour les amateurs des zones
incluant déconstruisent là pour le coup
au village autour c'est un pensons que
si les noirs prennent en f2 il va donner
la dame et prendre les deux tours il se
dit ok je peux prendre un échec la dame
va arriver là mais je veux défendre la
seconde rangée donc la petite exercice
pour vous est ce que darwin gaza lien
qui a bien calculé
et si vous pouvez quand même sacrifié un
f2 ou alors les blancs raison il faudra
autre chose donc répondez-nous dans le
tchat
si vous avez une idée si vous avez
calculé quelque chose et c'est que c'est
un calcul had le calcul de calcul donc
français mines prêts informels piscine
en 8 nos prières star industriel
apparemment du peuple sort désolé on n'a
pas fait la minute de silence
votre dépôt courant mary chan est au
courant je pense que si mais bon au
moins dans nos mis en pause on se met en
position opposée
on fait quelque chose pareil on pose une
question et verront guy mais me demander
à chacun à regarder
ok donc on achetait mais bon alors
personne ne répondant au tchad 1 on
attend enfin en attaque pour attendre on
attend comme le pape hockey plein mais
bon que j'apparaisse à un string sarlat
on peut feuilleter poudre mais du coup
ça là demain matin peut-être
éventuellement la tournée bien vu nous
le mettre sur la chaîne allait bien
c'est une belle partie enfin on a vu
tout à l'heure dans la journée c'est une
bonne partie transformé et du coup on
pourra faire un montage fr un résultat
final sans être celle de mazo puisse
allah on la mettra en dernier donc le
sens ça rend les salles de mazo avec un
résultat en cours et puis ça là on la
mettra en dernier en espérant que jova
manière on l'avait prédit mandat et
prédit on l'avait senti avec ses
lunettes de soleil alors ninja venir on
veut prendre le pion à f2 alors ok ninja
pour preuve de bon madame prend je suis
un peu obligé
comment tu continues et incomplètes en
fait ouais mais c'est bien pour vous en
faites un peu on fait ça ah oui sur sa
part flammes c'est pour vous forcer à
calculer et et voilà parce qu'en partie
en fait si vous êtes là peut-être vos
fichiers jeu pour comme sa voiture je te
prends mais normalement en fait en
général les gens sont assez sérieux et
[Musique]
efficace
2 tu te voir et qu'est ce que je raconte
m ouais en fait ok il faut être sûr
parce que en fait là vous à une très
bonne position à quesnoy à vue menées
vous avez une pression si on prend avec
deux condamnés deux tours contre la dame
est ce qu'on est toujours aussi bien
donc qui n'est déjà pas si c'est chaque
croix rouge puis dame b 2 ok c'est bien
jo ça c'est bien qu'elle a déjà un
cachet tapis il a trouvé le gain je
pensais ce qui a échappé à gavin jones
donc très bien jouer brandon finir cet
émirat pour garder quand tu es un peu
fous ta de l'eau partout où tu colmate
les brèches
non mais le seul truc qui est pas
évident en fait c'est ici quand on va se
position mon cas et l'abandonné pas ce
qu'il a vu canton férois j'ai un don
fait à m on pense beaucoup à ça en fait
pour le match et on oublie qu'en fait on
peut attaquer g2 de ce côté et donc bien
joué donc de la porte d'un jack qui a vu
d'hommes b2 et malheureusement fait les
gens ont peut rien intercepter les tours
sous l'emprise de calais cette emprise
donc c'est juste notre prochain enfin
auquel les banques peuvent attendre
trois couronnes en tout mais ils seront
quand même hâte après son retour c'est
d'eux que j'aurai un truc et ouais très
belle victoire et après l'autre option
c'était quoi cette partie en deux mais
je crois que j'ai en fait ouais mais je
moi si on pouvait pas voter non mais
comme ça aussi
bon les deux fondateurs l'onuci madère
l'autre david le g4 ont produit en fait
du coup fois je crois et 0 mais moi ça
va mater facile aussi un donc ouais vous
faire du mal et surtour ces deux juste
pour une fois je crois je te prends je
ne perdrai pas de temps ouais donc le
bain très très belle partie quoi d'obama
qui revient bien dans le test je sais
pas exactement quel classement mais il
doit pas être un hacker un demi point de
il est à un point derrière wayne qui
revient d'un demi point de l'ol est
sûrement demain il y aurait une partie
très importante dont trop walder sur
notre eau est probable ce qu'on imagine
notre famille watts escient il en est ou
sera tellement reduce finul
on cherchera pas une obsession ailleurs
et la finale il a fait nul son
adversaire ne s'est pas trompé dans un
bureau du bon côté tout ça on est et où
on est et par là à peu près mais pas mal
fermée alors bloqués dont qui s'est
passé après ce qu'on disait il est parti
à l'autre côté il n'est pas l'heure à 5
fermette pâte et ouais mais bien à nice
et là je donnais une plongée garde
pouvoir sont requis vingt cinq entrées
thématiques assez dans le délire
sécheresse qui ce compte là si tu fais
pas tu veux te retrouves à perdre parce
que en fait ce qui se passe tu le fais
pas le cauchemar entre guillemets c'est
déjà çà çà çà genre qui imagine que tu
connaisse pas le fric un fait ça il fait
ça et du coup de bloquer mode peut-être
le faire encore ce coup-ci nature dans
le faitout l'oubli encore si tu le sais
pas en fait tu je fais ça 5 est en fait
du coup là tu t'es fait avoir
ouais c'est le rendra pas le ton quand
on prend de prendre un jet de président
et donc mieux g4 qui est peut-être
éventuellement largement en gros il fin
je me rappelle c'est un truc qui est
montré très importante est très
importante des quatre nogué paito
d'encre en maths à 2600 l'école russe un
peu car c'est quoi ces on voir ont déjà
fait ça et donc scipion prend bien faire
rollin et puis le truc soit en réception
en a pas le foudre à venir le contrôle
est comme ça et puis on prendra celui là
et on rangera contrefous ok bon un petit
moment tu pourquoi des petits bull est
peut-être un petit truc pour la journée
on attendait on va demander à ma demande
à la galerie que la galerie le disent
c'est chaud
j'entendis pour dauphin s'est plaint
hippodrome ont constamment fait de
finale un stade de foot mais bon du coup
ils ont mis des chevaux vont sauter de
partout lorsque le chat est déjà dit
nous sur une autre partie si on laisse
qui est une bride sais je sais que vous
avez bien alors on peut faire ça bien
sûr on peut gérer notre partir
éventuellement
plutôt des beats portée taille et 3000
salaire 3 ou une seconde du blitz blitz
wade allez hop on espère qu'on va
trouver du client j'espère toujours
c'est parti c'est un bon client
qu'est-ce qu'on peut alors accordé
quatre buts sur sont re moi je pense que
oui j'essaye de jouer ce truc avec 3g
car il n'y a pas forcément jeu de foot
saint-cloud marqué sept fois en fait un
je déteste hommage à beau dur pour elle
va durer bonjour bauer grand spécialiste
de vente
c'est pas un truc comme ça où la
formation à saint cloud le tram mais si
j'essaye de me rappeler qu'il ya colin
ici je croteau 12e ou 4 ou les sorties
on prend des cinq coins d'infos dans
votre super lyon mais c'est plus ou
moins affûté mais c'est une sorte de
contre granby albin à l'envers mouais
pourquoi pas vous mâcher et est
originale
moi je vais faire car les lieux deux
équidés si les empêcher de sortir mais
ça va être problématique
si à leur cas et b4 plus de torfou et du
cou
la kf3 il va jouer sujet car je pense à
toi qui à eux deux je crois qu'il a joué
in d une des meilleures façons contre ce
système en fête avec ses 5 et a6 fac
dekalb et cinq nuits des bowlings le kg
dans l'esprit de bahadur way débat dure
mais fait son entrée avec effroi g4 va
dire je sais pas ce que tu as trop de
food et trompe je crois tu vois un truc
comme ça faut pas se prendre le club en
fait ce qui me paraît évident ici c'est
que je vais complètement méprisés en
fait je fais trois des deux et puis dans
l'esprit de bagur même pas d'heureux bon
bah non non mais pas leur faim pourquoi
rauque et qu'on trouvera des efforts
selon est très bien ici en fait
et du coup juste aller essayer de mater
en force tu vas y ait déjà un peu en pls
ramener la dame un peu plus loin et puis
ok tu en fais on ramène des pièces petit
à petit dans l'esprit de bahadur
peut-être tour g1 d'un match 4 tours h4
puis à les mater en force et par là bas
mais en fait je passe sur soi si pour ic
impulsion pour les blancs non mais
sûrement pour une juste mais pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas grave tu vois ce genre
tu joues comme ça franchement pas tu
vois je faire kf4 cash 5 en fait engagé
trois quarts aller à st gall tu te sens
ont poussé des ailes quoi ça donne
enfants piétons en face ouais c'est un
peu chiant comme une tour de l'enfer
pour défendre
du coup la 4g un peu dégoûté de ce coup
en cause au km5 un jeu pas mais on
essaie de faire f 5 un moment donné mais
je vois pas vraiment dans quel cas f5 ça
ne dérange pas trop je veux juste
prendre jusqu'à kg 3 et the mask épreuve
5 je veux pas vraiment sur le souci
c'est d'éviter le vote utilisé le kop
web je ne changerai pas
je sais jouer comme ça et sur quelques
transferts bat mi6 et s'est placé
quelques problèmes 5 quand même quand
même vous même le toqué g cup nous mêmes
par l attention pas attention à ça le
dernier roman aussi du coup 1
mais plus ça me fait chier dégage
ça m'a fait chier mangent pas assez joué
marc henri finale non mais tu as raison
le beau jeu qu'on est là pour s'amuser
aussi alors le beau jeu c'est quoi
depuis toute façon est encore des
chances pratique ici pas d'un kfc simple
ça embête un peu bas et je me barre non
ok c'est juste que j'ai envie d'avoir le
roi mieux placé au caire en juin skf 5
mont-royal c'est bien ici en fait tu
vois il fait comme toi quoi il a peur on
a compris l'enjeu devient sur le cavadee
sur les tours non mais il ya très très
peur en fait ça il comprend le danger
mastour cette tension qui comprend le
danger non mais là c'est pas simple du
tout point dans cette position surtout
que ça fonctionne et que vous ne filmez
ils sont courageux je suis passé très
bon ça je le mets bien sûr cette colonne
morris n'importe où le hockey je reviens
je pensais que c'est un peu de la merde
vas tu faire mieux que à nant dire qui
n'a pas su défendre notre chronique et
compte au moins et donc la suggestion de
robert s dans son article c'est de créer
des menaces toujours ou des pseudos
menace nucléaire croit qu et des menaces
et adam qui deviennent en panique
quels conseils fantastique génial j'ai
créé des fausses menaces mais l'autre
tant qu'ils y croient enfin moi je peux
six ans mais c'est en tout cas je vais
te mets là moi je suit en fait voilà
c'est fait et du coup bon juste qui a
pondu l'on est pas top
dukan est si prompt à f k challenge du
tarif si ces machins et sinon hockey qui
lie prend l'option à deux je m'en fiche
que franck a pas d'échec
à
d'échangés alain un peu d'options de
chaque côté c'est un peu compliqué qui
est passé tant à la pendule mais bon on
a fait le boulot
sté nul probablement j'ai pas fais
cramique y les sushis sont arrivés
attention ils sont là j'ai de faire
tomber on sent qu'il manque un petit
truc à il est déconnecté le taureau
connecte pas c'est le beau jeu
fantastique vêpres et mou ou chez nous
qui sommes déconnectés
ah non c'était nous qui étions
déconnecté du coup le beau jeu le beau
jeu n'a pas réussi à se faire plâtrer 10
comme titulaire du piémont et super fair
play on compte sur une déconnexion
jamais jamais non on veut faire une
revanche on a perdu plein de points je
sais 2520 ya pas si longtemps
voilà on fait le beau jeu on joue comme
tu veux non on fait toujours le beau
j'en reviens je crois comprendre ce qui
va se passer
c'est beau le reconnaître cette
formation des gars vous que ces trois
noms bout est ce qu'à fait refouler 5
pas attentatoire à faire et s'ils sont
utilisés la formation
[Musique]
bon ben ok toutes les pièces sont hors
champ ruiz
j'ai pas le droit de table sur une rue
ses parts à la kermesse ont calé en g3
par l jouer un peu attendre je temporise
est en fait j'avais une idée en fait
quand j'ai fait ça jamais en fait ne
peut pas vraiment dire ce que je voulais
faire tourner un peu mes pièces voix a
changé un peu de l'information moi je
sais pas si on a gagné au change de
changer de nom mais je sais pas non plus
à
prendre ça mais on va essayer d'aller
juste
enfin c'est pas l'impression que se
passe des choses
je suis un peu gêné souk alors j'ai 300
visites fermé 5 à 10 sont hostiles
séparés mais avait laissé son
compétiteur je le tronc des 5 m
il est lourd du très très bon choix
quant à lui pensé non je ressens
non mais là du coup nouveau truc que je
pensais cet écueil ceci juste précis à
massiac et j'ai cinq bons souhaits de
six roms non je vous jure ce patch 4 à 6
ans est secouru tous pourris que justin
je vois défendre comme on peut hein
mes coups j'ai super mal joué
de la tête 5e ayant tous différemment
super mal joué
4 je veux faire du beau jeu en fait
c'est un beau jeu c'est de faire d'un
malicieux
j'ai pas du style à lui sinon je vois
absolument rien trop fatigué
je tente un mais du coup ça craint grave
moi je vais pas aller là je vais ensuite
quelle horreur
peu de matériel de retard non mais je
vois pas grand chose je suis pas en
grande tu pas en grande forme
je veux un truc sérieux coup même le
battre deux fois avant de la vendre
avant de quitter
ma cote de retard d'une tour est une
pièce mais réfléchi comment il a du mal
il dit oui c'est très compliqué comme
position et simplifie mais est-ce que
ses rangs le beau jeu de jouer comme ça
pragmatique
certes certes
certes maison en vous non je suis pas
jamais
ces deux chiens fous prend et d'un
programme fait permis ici photo so
coopératif bah non il veut pas coopérer
mais on lui que malgré un tour de moins
absolument tout est changé c'est une
bonne dose de match 6 2 ce qu'on peut
abandonner
bon allez je pense qu'il faut vraiment
jouer une grotte je pense que si je
disais faut vraiment jouer sérieux là du
coup vraiment là grob qui peut être un
trou verture bout on dégage et hop on a
tous poussé partout avec le roi f1 comme
mehdi nous a appris j'ai fait j'ai
beaucoup de mal à jouer sérieusement là
c'est horrible et dans le monde non
c'est de faire ça comme ça
crêpage envie de sacrifier des trucs là
bas mais qui avait six marches pas bon
je vais faire quelque 4,6 en fait
commencé dur femmes
on voulait se connaître bah genre tout
dessus ni coupe là bas ils jouent
football quatre enfants ouais ouais
enfin on va trouver un vrai jeu parlant
comment le parquet
c'est quoi le pillage avec fuji un juge
on les fait rage six ans fait donc
thomas mux vous ça veut dire fou projet
4 où les gens apparaissent çà m'a parlé
tout à l'heure dans la dans la rue parce
tu es fou g5 tu perds un temps dans
l'es8 hockey non sport ou un piège même
fait les blancs fou j'ai cinq forfaits
h6 il rentre chez lui et toute façon h61
cook et n'aura joué puisque très souvent
les blancs ou un truc à base de genre
fou trois dames d2 ou food et d'audace
et un voyage en jet de fou donc
donc voilà c'est ça se dessine pas mal
là pour le moment la grèce quoi je suis
à une chance mais disent très fiers de
moi me disent très fiers de toi suisse
affiche adam ne sais pas comment je
voudrais faire une dame que l'e10 soit
fier d'emmener trois méga 4 s arrangeant
les sacrifiés souhait que j'aille faire
kiev 6 sacrés lecavalier mais je vois
pas de maths après
ok peut-être des perpète ou mauvais
c'est le beau jeu mais on fera pas le
père pète un sillon la fin joueur
parfaite c'est ce disque édifions hockey
à moins ce qu'ont fait sa crise de dames
perpète
jean pierre prend des cartes pour prend
arrive cette année dame prend des cartes
mais il peut soit 900 équipent leurs
yeux oui l'on tente pour bedie pêcheurs
6 par an à cinq têtes voyage oneworld
essaie d'être un ok mais pour mehdi fin
mais il voudrait consacrer cet ajout est
focal point que samedi les fameux projet
comprend des cadenas web albums il fait
beau je fais le beau jeu il veut gagner
même temps vu les deux prestations
précédentes il se dit je suis favori
mais attend
pas grand-chose grand chose
c'est mehdi mehdi mehdi qui joue avec
montpellier mais ibra kane et qui donc
qui franco marocain et qui vit à agadir
et qui adore la grob un g4 d'ailleurs le
délire est partie de julien sur la grave
il a déjà joué en partie longue et tout
mais des fois il m'envoie de ces partis
blitz sur sur internet
mais rien à dessein pas quoi enfin c'est
marrant mais l'a par exemple nous on se
bat là aussi non ça joue je voulais donc
mais dit un jour entre de 1250 et 2300
que pas mal de joueurs et je vais très
très bien mais dit ça il fait que des
graves tout cas sur internet au top 12
j'étais déçu j'ai pas vu du grand homme
il a ajouté 4 ok ça très décevant à sa
présidente
moi je veux du beau jeu du spectacle
non mais il fait pas le beau jeu non je
veux pas se mettre au feed
mais là on n'y arrive pas le matc
horrible
sans j'essaye un piéton pin mais
pourquoi tant pis j'ai envie de le mater
en fait je me fiche one on a gagné cette
partie
je veux absolument faire le beau jeu et
le beau jeu c'était d'essayer de placer
j'ai cette attaque de google ouais c'est
le beau jeu en fait de faire sa tête
faire petit rock en fait trois l'absolu
petit rock doit pas venir 50 ainsi que
ses courtiers rock et hum hum
finalement l'huile je sais mais bon je
voulais pas quand tu m'as compris
l'inutilité je veux pas gagner comme ça
mais j'ai plus de temps du coup aller
donne tout quoi ouais mais bon c'est
difficile parce qu'il est très rapide en
fait je le connais un petit peu et il
fait partie de la race des rapides ça
espèce de gobelins de niveau 6 1 les
gobelins sont très rapides faut le
savoir surtout que le soir d'orage quels
sont vos rêves juste insupportable
secteur je gagne parti je fais gobelins
sort de rage et où est le mec on pouvait
plus en fait je suis très très lent la
jeu très lentement
à
kim on va perdre
quel objet lecavalier mais tu sois plus
de temps font pression et gagnante 1
mais la gagnante
à
pourquoi le projet n'aura pas été
récompensés jamais on dernière du stream
allez hop bien parti on y va mais bon
c'est sympa points bon allez on va
tenter le bon bout ces poissons biplace
n'a pas de nom je pense notamment aux
mauvaises bases d'un match 5
je comptais faire croire 17 ans tu
tomberas oui ok alors comment ça joue sa
femme
ben je sais pas ok leurs spécialistes
manitowoc mayer ma spécialisation dans
ce groupe i j'ai beaucoup de mal
ça part très simple à jouer comme
birmingham be et en plus les blonds les
compensations
non ok ça ça va qu'il a recréé cette
fois là on va échanger sa normandie vite
durant un an et demi exactement me faire
roi des 8es en fait là je pense très
très grosse confrontation a fallu tout
cavalier déjà tornade dont peut-être
vous la tornade book value 5 mais
j'attaque le fou
j'ai un peu déçu bouquets simples en
fait on va faire quoi autre chose je
sais pas tu peux venir
bah en fait mef je sais pas tu vois j'ai
envie de faire d'anne decis après sur
pions prend cavaliers prend comme ça tu
vois mais ce qui est assez marrant c'est
qu'on ressent vraiment est à l'aise par
rapport à cette ouverture
bon ok on va prendre la pièce quand même
carey price chopper notre sort de notre
sort de rage
il a quand même jusqu'à et des quatre
moteurs quelques poèmes quelque 400 fois
donc je sentais partie pour ça tout ça
ça n'a aucun intérêt ce goût faire juste
dames c'est 600 fiches complètement fait
remarquer d'écart d'avoir juste dame ces
sept on recule une cage par une case and
on aime cet exercice et shannon descente
dames des salles du coup c'est sa beauté
d'antan et là du coup vous nos hauts
cris est pas content de chevaux savais
plus quoi ben non ils n'aiment pas les
chevaux tu qu'on n'arrive pas à faire le
beau joueur il ya une victoire même sans
beau jeu sur une victoire non aux
conceptions besoin de gagner ou pas
soixante faut que je raconte mes points
volonté à 25 gr
macquarie sur le beau jeu sur le stream
j'ai une idée de beau jeu mais bon oui
je perde un peu le pion
je pense pas que l'on réussisse à
j'arrive pas à trouver comment passer
femmes
je ne trouve pas
cherche d'accord
parce qu'il défend pas malin de force à
quitter cette colonne
ouais
heureusement je suis un peu dans la
merde tout connaître des relevés retour
à chiens et damages cette volonté oui je
sais ne finit pas non je peux pas
jouissif et g3 je suis vraiment dans la
merde
défendre de partout femme submergée par
des attaques de tous les côtés oui
j'aime je repars de l'autre côté c'est
tour palier pas c'est très chiant mais
moins alors on fait quand même ce que
lui il va lier ces tours en faire dans
ma chute aussi je dirai juste ça doit
gagner mais bon c'est pas mauvais non
plus tout ce que je pensais qu'ils
allaient faire et du coup j'arrive pas à
l'élite hourantier deadpool sautron des
soldes votée ce très mauvais je passe
pas le beau jeu fun qu'il faut j'ai
trois jeux phares d'un médecin
on est mal autant encore une fois ballon
quoi mais pas depuis des chèques et je
vais ressortir le roi comme ça je veux
monter ont fermé à l'aller perdu femme
se chauffe
elle peut encore lutter pour affûter
leur ensemble ouais à leroy ne s'en va
pas là comme quoi le rock des fonds on
la voit pas réussi au japon n'aura pas
réussi le beau jeu il est temps de
partir va souhaiter à tous une très
bonne soirée et on vous dit à bientôt